global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us we
begin tonight with some relief for
children and parents after weeks and in
some places months of an alarming
shortage of pain and fever medication
for children at the same time as
respiratory illnesses surge among that
vulnerable demographic
Health Canada says supplies are expected
to arrive early next week more than one
million bottles of foreign Source
children's ibuprofen and acetaminophen
will be earmarked for hospitals
pharmacies and retailers shelves have
been empty for some time Canada's chief
medical advisor calls it a perfect storm
that started last spring
where we had increased demand at a time
where we did not typically see that
increased demand and then that's the
time that the companies would normally
be replenishing stocks and then moving
forward to get ready for the fall and
the winter season so they didn't have
the opportunity to do that
even as more Supply arrives there's no
indication if it'll be enough to
alleviate the Nationwide shortage
meantime parents have been taking
Extraordinary Measures to get their
hands on the over-the-counter
medications Heather York's West has our
top story tonight
when it comes to finding medicine for
her kids this Calgary mom doesn't mince
words it's a disaster this is the nicest
way I could put it Corey Larson's
youngest son suffers from migraine
headaches so when she couldn't find
children's pain medication for him here
she looked to a relative in California
for help sourcing another country's
Supply the federal government has now
done the same after next week more than
one million bottles of product will have
entered Canada to supply hospitals
Community pharmacies and real retailers
and medications will start appearing on
store shelves starting early next week
Dr Sharma says it will be important to
read the labels carefully when using the
foreign sourced children's ibuprofen and
acetaminophen specific ingredients and
their recommended dosages may not be
what many Canadians are used to honestly
it's a huge relief that we're finally
getting a fever-reducing and pain
reducing medications for children the
last several months have been very
difficult for parents health Canada says
a number of factors contributed to the
shortage and even after manufacturers
doubled production demand outpaced
Supply unfortunately Canada has a bit of
a history I think of drug shortages when
it comes to Children and Youth in
particular so we are encouraging the
federal government to think about how do
we proactively ensure we have those
reserves in place but the triple threat
of RSV covid and the flu is already
overwhelming pediatric care across the
country it's scary what lies ahead
because we've started the season much
earlier and there's so many viral
illnesses going around and they're more
severe that severity highlighted by
tragic news this week out of Alberta
news of the province's first flu deaths
of the Season include a four-year-old
child a heartbreaking start to an
already anxious viral illness season and
the worst of it may still be to come
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
just incredible images coming out of
Buffalo New York a snowstorm has brought
the city to a standstill more than 120
centimeters of snow has fallen so far
and it just keeps coming Buffalo is just
over the border near Niagara Falls it's
situated right on Lake Erie so that
means Lake Effect systems usually hit
the city harder than the surrounding
region lifelong Buffalo residents are
used to bad storms but this one even
caught them off guard
see as soon as I'm done doing something
it's covering it right back up but
the longer you wait the harder it's
going to get so you try to get a little
bit of a rhythm and then eventually you
got to give up because you can't keep up
with it
schools are closed as well as Amtrak
stations in Buffalo and Niagara Falls
lots of flights in and under the Buffalo
airport we're also canceled and the
Buffalo Bills have moved their Sunday
game to Detroit as parts of New York are
under a state of emergency and
Commercial traffic is banned along a
stretch up the interstate let's go right
to Global's chief meteorologist Anthony
Farnell who joins us from Buffalo
tonight and the I mean you've seen your
share of storms what's it being like
today
uh it has been incredible and it started
when we got in last night and the snow
was basically a wall that just moved
through and lightning thunder it
continued basically the entire night
waking us up at times and this is the
end result now over 24 hours later and
about four feet or you mentioned 120
centimeters on the ground this is an
intersection this is a street I'm
walking on that just yesterday at this
time was completely bare there were
actually people out mowing their lawn it
was grass and now there's so much snow
and as we've been driving Street by
Street and around different
neighborhoods it's the same picture
everywhere snow and nowhere to put it
luckily plows have been out in full
force in the major streets are doing a
lot better than a lot of these secondary
thoroughfares residents here they're
used to snow storms what makes this so
special is the fact that it's fallen in
24 hours and it looks like it's going to
continue with another 30 to 50
centimeters by tomorrow Farah oh Anthony
Farnell in a waist deep snow in Buffalo
New York thanks Anthony
extreme weather events also dominated
discussions at the cop 27 climate Summit
in Egypt smaller countries have been
demanding compensation for bearing the
brunt of climate disasters despite
wealthier Nations causing the bigger
carbon Footprints now Canada is backing
the idea but it's also facing some
criticism Eric Sorensen explains
there was momentum and optimism at cop
27 to end the use of fossil fuels
Nations that will bear the brunt of
global warming and rising sea levels
hope the final communique will signal
intentions to phase out oil and gas
similar to language last year targeting
Coal Power we need to include all fossil
fuels not only coal in terms of facing
down or face out of coal power to
include oil and gas but consensus
appears to be slipping away and that's
unfortunate says this Canadian activist
at the summit despite the fact that
we've been hearing this from countries
for the last 10 days we haven't been
seeing it reflected in those draft
decision texts Canada does not support
language to phase out oil and gas the
minister for climate change says Ottawa
is committed to reducing that dependency
doubling its climate financing ending
fossil fuel subsidies investing in
e-vehicles all of these measures and and
many more will lead to a significant
reduction of our consumption of fossil
fuels and and therefore our dependencies
on fossil fuels but critics are
disappointed Ottawa doesn't support
clear language to wean the planet off
oil and gas it's really an abdication of
responsibility ability and it shows that
Canada is beholden to fossil fuel
lobbyist interests and not the welfare
of people around around the planet still
there may be other progress at cop 27
Canada is a driving force behind
creating a loss and damage fund for Less
wealthy countries it haven't been the
main cause of climate change but stand
to suffer the greatest harm I think
we're close to that we agree to the
creation of a fund cop 27 was scheduled
to wrap up by Friday but the host
country Egypt is now expected to produce
a final communique sometime this weekend
and there is optimism on that one big
sticking point to create a fund for
countries that will need help to cope
with the damage and increasing costs
coming from climate change Eric Sorensen
Global News
Ottawa
to Ukraine now half of the country's
power grid was forced offline today as
many as 10 million people were affected
by emergency blackouts and damaged
infrastructure temperatures are freezing
and electrical crews are struggling to
stay on top of repairs as Crystal
gemancing Reports with winter closing in
pressure is growing on an already
strained power supply
in Wartime life without power can seem
like nothing compared to the darkness of
occupation
Vitali zodiac is just one of many Herson
residents now sharing details of Russian
interrogations and beatings with Ukraine
again controlling the city efforts are
underway to provide people with food
water and electricity but with the
Russian Onslaught against the energy
Network it won't happen quickly and
residents are being encouraged to leave
Ukraine's grid remains firmly in
Russia's crosshairs the suffering
ukrainians are experiencing is
increasing as the temperature drops
Alexander huroshenko says without
electricity water treatment plants don't
work heating systems go cold and cities
are plunged Into Darkness nobody sits
with the hands in their pockets I was
talking to one of the directors and they
say we just finished another repair but
every strike means more work and every
repair requires new replacement parts
which are now scarce rolling blackouts
allowed the country to share available
energy but Russia is squeezing that
Supply
I think there's a tactic to take people
by exhaustion but people are tough he
says and they're prepared to wait for
victory even if it means sitting in the
dark
Crystal gomancing Global News London
new technologies like Hypersonic
missiles drones and even disinformation
are changing the way Wars are fought
today at CFB Halifax Canada's defense
minister Anita Anand announced a
proposal to make that location North
America's Regional headquarters for a
new NATO Innovation Hub
it will enable close collaboration with
NATO's best as we sharpen our
technological Edge through development
in artificial intelligence big data
processing Quantum enabled Technologies
and biotechnology
and then says the goal of the Hub is not
to build weapons but to fuel better
cooperation between NATO and the tech
sector
Elizabeth Holmes the disgraced founder
of theranos has been sentenced to more
than 11 years in prison the 38 year old
was convicted earlier this year on fraud
and conspiracy charges theranosa's blood
testing technology was found to be a
sham patients were endangered investors
were defrauded
hundreds of employees at Twitter resign
coming up the ultimatum that led to even
more chaos within the social media Giant
in a surprise reversal fans at the World
Cup won't be able to buy alcohol at
stadiums FIFA made the announcement with
just two days before the opening game in
Qatar alcohol will still be sold at
other licensed venues and fan
destinations now this is a dramatic
change to the requirement Qatar agreed
to to secure the world's biggest
sporting event it's also a major blow to
Budweiser's 75 million dollar
sponsorship deal with FIFA alcohol is
heavily restricted in Qatar a
conservative Muslim Emirate
now to the turmoil at Twitter where
hundreds of employees have called it
quits opting out of an ultimatum issued
by the new owner Elon Musk to either
sign up for longer more intense working
hours or leave
we're all about to get fired from
Twitter that's the thing I've been nine
years and nine months now
some employees who've given years of
service are outraged telling musk
exactly what they think offices are
empty doors are locked and users are
bracing for the platform to go dark at
any moment here's Ross Lord on the chaos
hey everyone with each passing day
there's a consensus building about Elon
Musk that being a brilliant engineer
does not guarantee success in running a
social media platform it's a complete
and utter mess right now since he spent
44 billion dollars buying Twitter musk
has alienated users with a plan to make
verified accounts pay a monthly fee and
he's laid off large sections of his
Workforce this week issuing an ultimatum
that Twitter 2.0 must be extremely
hardcore and staffers must sign up for
long hours at high intensity or leave
immediately hundreds of Twitter
employees are leaving and so not only
are we worried now that there might be
technical problems
um with with Twitter but now we might
see problems with uh
uh just being able to ensure that the
user data is handled in the way that
they say it it's going to be handled
using the hashtag love where you worked
many of those leaving chose to Express
gratitude for jobs they found rewarding
but musk's puzzling Maneuvers and
erratic online presence have some
observers suggesting he's in over his
head the equivalent of asking the
plumber to come in and wire up your
house and do all your electrics Elon
Musk the engineer trying to solve
problems when he should be thinking not
about engineering tactics but about
social tactics and how to deal with a
business that is a social business it's
a Communications company it's not a
rocket company under the hashtag R.I.P
Twitter reactions range from attempts at
humor to more serious Reflections about
Twitter's role in advancing human rights
and Justice there are some who say musk
could still succeed if he finds the
right replacement staff and by expanding
Twitter for things like mobile payments
and food delivery they say if the
turmoil continues though it could invite
government intervention something that
would not sit well with a free speech
purist like Musk Ross Lord Global News
prime minister Justin Trudeau wrapped up
his stop at The aipac Summit in Bangkok
though not exactly on the note he would
have preferred Trudeau's agenda was
sidetracked by an emergency meeting over
another North Korean missile launch as
Mackenzie gray reports it's once again
put the security up that region and
other allies at the Forefront and what
Canada can do to ensure it
the Prime Minister wrapping up his Quick
Stop in Bangkok where the focus was
supposed to be on trade but once again
international events derailed that plan
a North Korean missile launch the
aftermath shown from a fighter jet the
Japanese defense Ministry saying it
landed just 200 kilometers off the coast
but had the potential to hit North
America
the North Korean test leading to an
emergency meeting on the sidelines of
aipac Trudeau joined by U.S vice
president Kamala Harris and other
Western allies in condemning Pyongyang
together the countries represented here
will continue to urge North Korea to
commit to serious and sustained
diplomacy Canada already participates in
Naval operations to enforce U.N
sanctions on North Korea but true to
hinted Canada's role could expand in our
upcoming indo-pacific strategy you'll
see that we'll be making new Investments
to enhance the Canadian Armed Forces
engagement in the region selling his new
Asia strategy was the goal of this trip
but International incidents like
Trudeau's conversation with Chinese
president Xi Jinping at the G20
overshadowed everything else Trudeau
wouldn't say if he spoke with she again
at APEC I was in a number of sessions
over this this particular Summit with
President XI and I was very clear in all
my interventions with all leaders
that it's important that we continue to
focus on the things that matter for
Citizens the prime minister is now off
to his final Summit of this 10-day trip
left francophone in Tunisia June is
expected to meet with other world
leaders while he's there but his first
sit down tomorrow is actually with a
Canadian Quebec Premier Francois Lago
Farah
Mackenzie gray in Bangkok Thailand thank
you
[Music]
made in Canada next the armored vehicle
manufacturer making key contributions to
Ukraine's war effort
foreign
it has been nearly nine months since
Russia launched its war on Ukraine and
through it all Western allies have been
backing Ukrainian forces with billions
in key weapons and military equipment
and that includes Canada armored
personnel carriers designed and built in
Ontario are part of that contribution
Mike troulet gives us an exclusive look
inside Rochelle a company booming with
business
the vehicle is called the senator it
says up armored as it is high-tech and
while its intended use was to get in and
out of dangerous areas quickly the
ukrainians have taken to adding Armament
and using them for shock attacks
virtually the entire vehicle is
manufactured right here and Company CEO
Roman shimanov says two new vehicles are
completed every day and promptly sent
off to support ukrainians so here you
can see the vehicles in different stages
over here you can see how people
grinding in this vehicle will be ready
for paint today
and ready for paint today two days yeah
yeah so every day as I mentioned we need
to prepare two vehicles people that were
delivering those vehicles to are under
much more precious than us Canada paid
for eight Senator apcs that have long
since been delivered but 19 more have
been bought and paid for by NATO and
European allies and there's another
hundred in the pipeline it's great news
for Rochelle just a six-year-old startup
with a couple of hundred employees 30 of
whom are ukrainians who recently arrived
in Canada like Vladimir who are proud of
what they're building to help push the
Russians back
the Warriors the heroes the strong
people they are fighting there and
defending the Homeland he says we are
helping as much as we can but we are not
as strong as they are Rochelle has grown
so quickly even defense experts we spoke
with don't know much about them so we'll
take you inside the plant for a
first-hand look at how they do it let's
talk to some Ukrainian Special Forces
soldiers who use them every day pharah
thanks Mike and you can watch Mike's
full report tomorrow at seven right here
on global on the new reality and that's
global national for this Friday night
I'm Farah Nasser tonight's your Canada
is leading tickles it's a town of around
300 people in Newfoundland and Labrador
and it's beautiful as you can see thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow until then take care of
yourselves and each other good night
thank you